if you could have any one of the other
spider-man villains in the Marvel
Universe with you what one would you
choose
maybe venom but at the end of day that's
that's kind of above my paygrade and
also it's not my daddy's tractor so I
don't know where it fits it in the grand
scheme II think so I would never rule
anything out hey everybody it's Charlie
more huge news you may have seen this
morning the Sony announced that it plans
on eventually using spider-man inside
its venom spider-verse that it's
creating the backdoor way that we found
out about this was because of what's
going on with the venom movie it hasn't
been rated yet but we all assumed that
it was being pitched as an r-rated film
so I'll explain what this means what
Sony's timeline is and what the terms of
their sharing arrangement with Marvel is
for the spider-man character because a
lot of it has to do with what happens
with the next couple of spider-man films
that Marvel makes including Avengers 4
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's a new infinity war
blu-ray giveaway going on all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
it's a good news bad news situation I'll
start with the bad news first so we
found out that venom is probably going
to wind up being pg-13 I mean we wanted
to honor the comics with the movie
tonally and as I think we can all agree
venom is one of the darkest comic book
characters and so it seems appropriate
that the movie would also be dark
because we want to do justice to the
true nature of venom which is a
brain-eating alien that occupies Sony is
pushing to get venom the most edge Lord
pg-13 rating that you could possibly get
before it becomes an AR film which
usually just means less blood and gore
like there's a scene in the trailer
where he talks to the guy in the street
while he holds him up about eating his
entrails that's actually right out of a
spider-man comic book the first
appearance of venom is a villain then he
legit bites this guy's head off in the
convenience store and they play it for
comedy
I so many tracks from the little time
eat on both legs
and everybody to face right of your head
you will be this honest
Nikolas faithful think you going down
the street
[Music]
oh there's no blood you don't see it
happen but you know that it happens
that's pg-13 biting heads off the
rated-r version of that would just be
showing the entire thing with blood
spraying everywhere
it'd be like Quentin Tarantino levels of
blood if it were gonna be true are
pushing the envelope and so it remains
to be seen the movies not rated at the
present so it's kind of a bummer that it
sounds like it's gonna wind up being
pg-13 I mean I'll still go see it I'm
sure it'll still be fun but it won't be
quite as crazy as we originally expected
it to be the whole reason why they're
pushing for this pg-13 rating is so that
it won't preclude or cause problems when
they try to cross spider-man over with
these venom and spider-verse characters
now remember Sony's making a whole bunch
of other spider-man films it has access
to nine hundred characters because they
own spider-man so right now there's the
Morbius movie there's the Kraven the
hunter movie they split the blackcats
silver sable movie into separate movies
so it'll be like a black cat solo film
then a silver sable film by themselves
the silk spider-man spin-off there's a
jackpot movie there's a Night Watch
movie so they have a bunch of obscure
characters that are developing too and
it's all built on the promise that
someday they'll be able to sew it
together with the Peter Parker
spider-man character so the whole reason
why they want venom to be pg-13 is so
that it won't cause problems when they
try to cross him over down the line
because per Marvel Disney and Sony's
business models the spider-man character
will never be rated R or appear as a
main character in rated our film so it
just causes a lot of problems if they do
an r-rated venom film then they want to
do venom vs. spider-man and they make it
pg-13 like oh they watered the venom
character done it's easier from a
marketing standpoint to start out with a
pg-13 venom so that when you cross them
over you don't have to totally change
the character that much but a lot of
Sony using the Tom Hollands spider-man
in these venom spider-verse films
depends on what happens with their
sharing arrangement with Marvel in the
next couple of years they've only got
two more films on their contract and
that includes Avengers 4 and spider-man
far from home so after spider-man far
from home next summer if Sony wants to
they can take the spider-man character
and do
ever they want to with them they don't
have to let Marvel use them anymore but
I think as fans what we're all hoping is
is that Sony will choose to extend their
contract and give Marvel and Cu access
to all their spider-man characters like
anybody from the sinister six that they
want to put in other people's movies and
in exchange for that they'll build a
bridge so that venom can appear in an
MCU movie that Marvel makes but right
now Marvel doesn't have any interest in
the venom character so Sony wants to
make all these films it has nine hundred
characters but they can't really do a
good job of that without the Peter
Parker spider-man character so they need
something from Marvel and Marvel needs
something from them so bare minimum we
still have till next July before
spider-man far from home comes out and
they have at least that long to
renegotiate a new contract to extend
whatever their existing deal is or
modify it like originally they were
gonna use Kraven in the Black Panther
movie Sony controls that character so if
they were gonna let them use a sinister
six character before it stands the
reason that that's already part of their
sharing arrangement Tom Holland has said
that he wants to work with Tom Hardy Tom
Hardy has said that he wants to work
with Tom Horne
they love each other so the Tom's will
probably eventually make a movie
together but what that movie is and what
the story is really depends on which
studio is making the film so with venom
crosses over into the MCU and Marvel is
the person to make that that it probably
winds up being the two of them teaming
up against sinister six characters if it
winds up being more of a Sony film then
it would probably be spider-man in venom
versus carnage and they would just do
maximum carnage because it's basically
what that story was like up to that
point venom had been fighting spider-man
back and forth for a long time but then
carnage became a thing and he was so
much worse so it's like okay fine we
have to put our differences aside to
take down this maniac that's why they've
tiptoed around Venom's comic book origin
and his visual style in the venom movie
so that they can cross him over with
spider-man it won't break the space-time
continuum but on top of this you can
kind of see how Sony really wants to do
a Thunderbolt style series of villain
movies with sinister six characters
remember before the whole Sony hack and
before they made the deal with Marvel
Drew Goddard who's doing Deadpool 3 the
x-force movie right now at Fox was
originally developing a sin
six team up movie at Sony so that was
all back during Andrew Garfield era like
that's why amazing spider-man to set up
all those sinister six characters
because that was gonna be their next big
team-up film so Sony still wants to do
that sinister six are really big
bankable characters but right now it
seems like they're sort of locked into
this sharing deal with Marvel so Marvel
gets to use them which is probably why
Sony hasn't started to make a green
goblin film just because he's waiting in
the queue for future MCU spider-man film
but don't expect to hear anything about
that until they start promoting
spider-man far from home next year which
will be around the time Avengers four
drops in theaters that's also probably
when they'll start dropping trailers for
spider-man far from home post all your
reactions in the comments below there
was a bunch more comic book news from
Marvel and DC that drop so I'll try to
get to that as fast as possible but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last video whale courage
a please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn about
Disney's plans for Fantastic Four
Deadpool and the x-men franchises and
click here for that new Captain Marvel
Easter egg scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you